valentine's Day is just around the
corner and it doesn't have to be about
reservations and busy restaurants of
course you can celebrate in the comfort
of your own home and make it just as
delicious registered dietitian Abby
sharp is here with some fantastic
recipes to create those staying in vibes
for Valentine's Day welcome thank you I
love that one time today hey look well
if it's gonna look like this i love it
too well people we think you know the
way to a man's heart is through his
stomach i think the same thing for us
ladies right we like to be cooked for as
well especially when there's some
chocolate involved yep so I've made a
full three-course meal using chocolate
and we're gonna do our chocolate dip fix
with a little goats cheese mousse in
there and some pistachios beautif right
that's a great present so gorgeous so
nice so it's a really simple recipe
honestly there's only a few ingredients
so the key is to use the best quality
ingredients so I always start with green
and blacks organic chocolate it's made
with all organic fairtrade ingredients
and they really pay attention to the
quality from being all the way to bar
okay so i'm using the maya gold flavor
from green black's it's got a little bit
of orange essence goes really well with
the figs that can jam eNOS of that thing
yeah we've got some samples for you
don't worry lies on yeah good idea first
thing in the morning yeah I'm so basics
good so good a nice little bit of orange
juice and spices so this melts over we
call double boiler so a little bit of
water in the bottom of a pan just
simmering very gently you let it gently
melt fat chocolate cuz it's such high
quality you don't want to scorch it and
then I've got these gorgeous ripe figs
now figs are often thought of as a real
aphrodisiac just like chocolate right
because a lot of people think that figs
were the kind of original forbidden
fruit in the Adam and Eve sorry oh not
yet right not the eyes it might be the
fig so basically I just cut a little x
marks the spot on the top of the fig
yeah we're gonna dip this into our
beautiful maya gold chocolate just you
know about you know freak or a quarter
or half way up drizzle that around just
so you can get rid of the excess onto a
baking sheet lined with something
nonstick like parchment paper or wax
paper then quickly will do the filling
which is literally just some chef which
is a ghost
nice soft goat cheese and we've
lightened it up with some fat-free plain
Greek yogurt so that it can be the trick
for anything right love that stuff Greek
yogurt it's like my go-to my go-to
ingredient for literally everything yep
so just like that and I've just taken a
little bit of orange zest which really
complements the orange flavor in that my
a goal right and basically you just pop
this into a into a piping bag if you
don't have a piping bag because I know
you don't need to get all fancy pants on
though you just get a little plastic bag
put it into your plastic bag snip the
corner out and boom boom you got a gay
guys like a ziploc exactly okay just
kind of feed it in there squeeze until
you've completely filled that up yep
just like that and then you know you
garnish with some of these beautiful
pistachios and you're gonna build rizla
honey it's a first course or even serve
it as a changeup even got a chocolate
sauce on the steak which I occurred I do
so basically you know chocolate is not
just for dessert anymore we paid a
beautiful beef tenderloin with a little
port wine and chocolate reduction dark
chocolate I've used the eighty-five
percent by green and blacks because that
way you get that kind of real bitter
sweet element yeah oh it's all looks so
beautiful a be sharp she's a registered
dietician thank you so much and great
tips I want to do that one you're
watching global we'll be right back